not everyone who the uk government
wanted to evacuate last summer got out
a year on we've heard multiple accounts
from people scattered across afghanistan
and the wider region in fear of their
lives
i'm really afraid and i'm still hiding
including a former translator for the
british army who's fought a legal battle
to get to the uk and having won is still
awaiting instructions about how to leave
the country
i'm feeling so unhappy i'm live
like in a present
my message to the british army we saved
the life of the british soldiers and now
it was the time that they have to save
my lives and my family lives
the former translator is one of
750 people accepted for relocation but
still thought to be stuck in afghanistan
and it's believed there are around 8 000
more afghans including their dependents
who could also be eligible to come to
the uk
how are you and your family generally at
the moment solicitor siddiqui says the
client he's speaking to is one of six
translators he's represented in legal
challenges against the british
government having worked for the british
army this man says he can't understand
why his application has been refused i
can't get back to afghanistan i have to
go somewhere else
the former translator has managed to
escape to pakistan with the help of the
canadian government and is living with
his wife and five children in a hotel
room pending the outcome of a second
judicial review into his case
the overall handling of the scheme
despite the numerous assurances
by the government has been
appalling these individuals if they
didn't have the legal representation
they
would have just been stranded and left
left in afghanistan or
in the third country where they have no
right of residence
the withdrawal from kabul was chaotic
now 120 000 relocation applications to a
scheme for those who worked for and
alongside the uk's armed forces have
been made although many are thought to
be duplicates
they include a woman we spoke to in
turkey who served in the special forces
of the afghan army
the turkish authorities are deporting
people back to afghanistan which
terrifies her you can't see her tears as
we talk as we're protecting her identity
do you regret
fighting in the afghan army alongside
the british
i do not regret but when i'm thinking
about my current situation by uh i am
living in another country
and i am completely for god
especially by the british government
other people we've spoken to describe
the relocation schemes as arbitrary
who was a translator for the british
army and is now in the uk is on the
phone to his sister in afghanistan
he says he knows people who've been
allowed to bring their extended families
yet he's not received a reply to his
application
he shared these photos which he says are
the taliban at his family's front door
looking for him
muhammad claims this video is of his
father after being beaten by the taliban
last october forcing the family to
barricade themselves inside their home
for safety
it's unfair to be honest one family here
other family we we all serve with the
british government it's good luck for
them people who are
who manage to come to the uk under the
scheme
but the whole scheme is confusing
including last summer's evacuation 10
000 afghans have been relocated to the
uk
asked about the time taken to process
claims since the fall of kabul the home
office says successful applicants are
subject to security checks
the ministry of defense says it regrets
delays as it works through complex cases
and will continue to do all it can to
secure safe passage for eligible afghans
lisa holland sky news